je m'appelle une page et 11 ans je joue
roanne je m'appelle 300 matches j'ai 12
ans et demi et j'ai joué à l'olympique
lyonnais
les footballeurs sont venus des quatre
coins de la france pour participer à la
danone nations cup l'un des plus gros
tournois pour les enfants âgés de 10 à
12 ans pour cette édition 2010 8 la
compétition était organisée ce samedi 21
avril sur les terres de l'équipe de
france à clairefontaine
le fait de venir à clairefontaine une
année coupe du monde pour ses enfants
filles et garçons
bah je pense que c'est une forme
d'aboutissement en tout cas on essaye de
leur proposer à une part du rêve que
veut provoque proposé l'événement à
moyen terme eu parmi les 80 formations
engagées le restera pas envoyer une
équipe masculine et féminine
ça fait toujours plaisir parce que c'est
un endroit où des pros ils ont joué
enfin qui joue et il ya beaucoup
d'adversité mai
on essaye de donner le maximum de nous
pour pour essayer d'aller le plus loin
possible
les performances réalisées devant les
yeux de leurs parents elle en a pas
dormi de la nuit
il s'est réveillé vraiment heureux c'est
sa journée eh ben c'est le rêve d'un
enfant aujourd'hui qu'il exauce beaucoup
d'émotion on voit beaucoup de choses les
enfants enfin c'est très plaisant de
voir autant d'enfants jouer avec des
grandes équipes c'est vraiment très très
très intéressant de participer à cet
événement le estrade terminera
finalement la 28e place du tournoi avec
une victoire de prestige 4 à 0 contre le
paris saint germain et qui pourra se
consoler également avec le titre de
champion du fair play
les deux finalistes joueront quant à eux
le 20 mai à montpellier